nous députés européens du moins
démocrates ceux tenus en voulaient c'est
aujourd'hui un message qui se résume en
deux mots remerciements et espoir
remerciements pour le confinement que
vous observez chez vous comme nous mêmes
le faisons remerciements pour nos
soignants remerciements pour ceux qui
font tourner quand même notre économie
en télétravail dans les entreprises
stratégiques et puis également espoir
parce que l'espoir c'est tous ensemble
par le confinement par ce travail que
nous faisons que nous allons vaincre la
maladie
le monde l'europe la france sont
aujourd'hui dans une situation
exceptionnelle une crise sanitaire sans
précédent
alors moi je vous demande qu'une seule
chose aujourd'hui c'est de rester chez
vous pour lutter contre la propagation
de ce coronavirus protéger notre
personnel de santé mais aussi les
personnes qui travaillent dans des
supermarchés dans les magasins
alimentaires dans les services publics
et dont nous avons plus que jamais
besoin pour vivre
alors moi je donne l'exemple je suis
députée européenne comme tous mes
collègues nous travaillons puis chez
nous nous nous préparons pour sortir de
cette crise il a géré pendant le
confinement notre travail continue le
parlement européen
il est chez nous comme des millions de
françaises et de français nous
télétravail on nous sommes en contact
très régulier avec notre délégation
renaissance avec nos collègues européens
du groupe renew est aussi avec nos
commissions et bien sûr parce que nous
sommes chez nous nous sommes au contact
du local en lien avec les préfectures
pour suivre la situation dans nos
départements lutter contre cette
pandémie
ce n'est possible qu'avec une
coopération européenne et internationale
le principe de solidarité ne doit pas
avoir de frontières car ce virus n'en a
pas cette situation elle nous appelle à
mener une réflexion sur l'unité aurait
peine notre dépendance avec de nombreux
acteurs sont de nombreux secteurs et
nous invite à bâtir une europe
souveraine la crise sanitaire que nous
traversons n'est pas sans lien avec la
crise environnementale la perte de
biodiversité sur laquelle nous
continuons de travailler y compris
aujourd'hui dans notre confinement mon
deuxième message c'est pour évoquer la
formidable résilience de l'être humain
dans des conditions extrêmes des deux
tours du monde me l'ont prouvé à
condition de faire des gestes qui
préserve les gestes qui sauvent
prenez soin de vous